do you have a hope that maybe
theoretical physics will open the door
to some exciting propulsion systems yeah
I do I think we're still at the very
infancy of our understanding of
everything and how things work and you
know 100 years ago it would be stupid to
try to predict the things we know today
and who knows like even you know I think
about things like James Webb looking
deeper into our solar system than ever
before and physically being able to see
objects that we just have not even been
able to physically see before on being
able to study black holes for example uh
better or better this stuff that's
happening outside of black holes at the
edges of black holes and how the
information is stored uh the uh
holographic principles just there's so
much weirdness black holes yes around
where gravity starts bending light
it's like all right we get to look at
that now and start to wonder like what
is going on and how can we like use that
somehow exactly propulsion I mean it
seems like awfully crazy and futuristic
at this moment but I think that's
because we know almost nothing about
um you know that those kinds of objects
where again where the general relativity
and quantum mechanics start to start to
um have to be both considered to
describe those kinds of objects and as
we study those objects we might figure
out some kind of unification thing that
will allow us to uh understand maybe how
to use black holes to for propulsion
like yeah
I could say a lot of crazy things but
like basically but the point is it'd be
stupid for us to even guess about things
we don't even know about yet you know
what I mean like and so therefore I'm
not going to say that the best option
for Interstellar travel is
nuclear drives like that could be like
someone saying you know in 1600 the only
way to fly is by strapping a thousand
Birds to your head you know like
but that said I mean everything you're
saying is right but the human history is
such like at the beginning of the 20th
century physicists Rutherford they
everybody this This brilliant people
that said we've basically solved all of
it right if you talk to most physicists
I think they're going to say like we've
pretty much
solved like the standard model describes
physics extremely accurately right uh
general relativity explains the cosmos
as we observe them extremely accurately
yeah there's a whole Dark Matter Dark
Energy things whatever yeah but uh
outside of that so like we basically
solved like
like where are you going to find gaps in
knowledge that are going to somehow
create warp drives or something like
that so wormholes uh but uh that's it
seems like throughout history we prove
ourselves wrong time again yes no I and
I this is well outside of any of my
knowledge base so I want to make sure
that if I say anything stupid it's
because I'm just a peasant here in
physics land but yes
um we're all peasants in physics land
but I really just think like it's very
humbling that we're still using chemical
propulsion and and variant cell like
injecting mass to to propel ourselves
and I I and no matter how you get at it
and I think someday I I would expect
that our species has figured out a way
to to get beyond that